ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
children of all ages please gather round
will have some special for you I want to
reduce the one the only Nicholas Scott
hi everybody
say hello everybody I don't let go
Nicola you are known for drawing one
character in particular least it's your
favorite character not mistaken correct
I yes so today we're doing a mirror
sketch I assume no think everyone knows
I was thinking about it but then I was
I'm just a character if I'm not mistaken
Wonder Woman is the reason why I decided
to draw comics in the first place
because Linda cada was my first
superhero she was my first exposure to
superheroes and there was no going back
for me and when I was in my mid-twenties
and trying to work out what the hell I
was gonna do with the rest of my life I
just thought to myself gosh I wish I
could just draw Wonder Woman because I
do draw Wonder Woman when I'm sitting on
the phone and scribbling away and
straight away it was like oh my god
that's a real job that someone has right
now in an industry that's food secret oh
my god I love superheroes I'm gonna do
that and I didn't know anything about
comics at the time there is in the same
comics culture in Australia certainly
not in the 70s as there was here even
though there were some comics available
it was not the same and I didn't find an
entry point for me when I was young so
my my entry point to see various was
film and TV well so wasn't really until
I decided I was gonna do this for a
living that I started reading coming you
mentioned that like there wasn't as much
of an outlet growing up in Australia but
like how early did you get into drawing
cuz if I'm not mistaken you kind of got
into in an interesting way with your mom
yes oh I I started drawing really young
because my mother is an artist of was an
artist my grandmother was an artist and
so the culture of was very dominant in
my family growing up so we were all sort
of given my sisters and I and my cousins
were all given that about materials to
play with
encouraged and sort of you know taught
how to use them I think it just sort of
took a little bit more with me than it
did with my sisters even though they're
both artistic in different ways for me
it kind of took in I'm the youngest by
quite a quite a distance and um that
meant that when I was little and my mum
would go up to do like life drawing
classes this is in the 70s instead of
leaving me with my sisters to to babysit
me she'd take me with her and I would
just sit in on laughs drawing classes
when I was like 4 and today normal yeah
so you know I would stop I started by
sort of taking her quick sketches if
these sort of beautiful fleshy women I'd
stop putting Wonder Woman boots on them
and giving them lots of hair and it was
all very messy like it like a
four-year-old drawers but it got me sort
of used to being in that kind of
environment and slowly but surely my mum
would sort of teach me how to look at
the model and draw what I saw and
eventually she'd just give me my own
paper on my own chuckles and just they
draw the model and which I started doing
and so I sort of got very used to
drawing Anatomy and looking looking at
it and how it worked and sort of balance
and and body language really young but I
hadn't really thought that I would make
a career out of being an artist because
I decided when I was young that I was
gonna be an accident and so I was
studying acting and when that career
didn't go anywhere
at least not I was life trying to work
out what else I was gonna do and the one
thing that I knew I could do was draw
and it was like what am I gonna do with
that to make a living and I spent quite
a long time before I came to the
realisation that oh my god I could draw
get paid to draw my favorite thing in
the world
if I get into this American industry of
which I know nothing and and so that was
the the beginning for me so I want to
ask you about your process yeah so I've
noticed that you sort of start you're
starting with the face here but you but
in particular have like an interesting
process when it comes to how you layout
your drawings correct yeah what I'm sort
of doing a page of Avadh I tend to like
everybody does I some nail I didn't I
tend to do my thumbnails in the margin
of the script so that I've got them all
together but when I get out my sort of
upwards to start on the finished thing
they look if you can see the blue line
the blue line stuff on here that sort of
breakdown in the grid they look just
like this except they're you know quite
a bit bigger and with a blue pencil if
I'm just penciling with a blue pencil
I'll do like a really rough breakdown of
my thumbnail just enough to give me the
sense of the composition but then I turn
on my light box and I flip it over which
is blank doesn't look like that it's
just look like one piece of eight paper
I turn on my light box and then I do all
of my rafts on the back of the page so
it's it's backwards in its storytelling
right but I've already sort of worked
out my storytelling in the in the
thumbnail but the the the detailing and
getting my Anatomy right and getting my
my storytelling right and getting my
faithful and facial expressions right
all of that I do on the back of the page
because doing doing roughs I want it to
be kind of loose and organic I want to
get as much sort of natural dynamic
shape in there as possible I don't want
anyone looking stiff and so you draw
really loosely and then you sort of
refine and refine and refine and refine
and I just find if I do that on the
front of the page it makes for quite a
messy finished pencil quite a rough
finish pencil and I like my pencils to
be really tight really
clean so that once I've done all of my
roughs then I'd have loads of detail on
there they've got the structure they've
got buddy language I get my faces and my
hands right and you know they're usually
covered in perspective lines then I flip
it over apart from like a tube that you
know the clean side and apart from like
a few very faint guide lines
I've got nothing there I've got a really
clean surface and I can then draw the
finish pencils really fast which gives
them some energy but really detailed and
really clean without doing too much
rubbing out and if I'm inking my own
work I'll just go straight winking I
don't I don't bother doing finish
pencils Alissa's of a particular facial
expression that I'm still playing with
you know your your the the the reason
why I started sort of flipping over was
because when you flip over an image and
it's suddenly facing the opposite way
it's a immediate way to give yourself a
fresh perspective a fresh eye where you
know usually you need to sort of walk
away and come back to it and look at it
afresh to see what the mistakes are if
you just flip it over on the lightbox
you see where the mistakes are
immediately or you see where it's not
quite conveying the information that you
want to convey as effectively and I find
that a lot of with a lot of really
subtle facial expressions I try to keep
them not too cartoon even though I love
that style it's just not a style that
I've developed so there's a subtlety to
my emotions which means that I need to
really get them right because otherwise
they'll be misinterpreted well you
mentioned sort of figuring out the
different facial expressions and you
mentioned your acting background yeah I
had heard that you kind of use that
training maybe a little bit to figure
out how you're gonna do certain scenes
and things like that theatre training
has done so much for my comic book
storytelling because I know how to block
a scene I know where all of my
characters are in any given space you
know I'm very sort of three
dimensionally aware whether it's in a
room
or an open-space I've got a really good
idea of how to keep the consistent scale
and I know where everybody is and you
know as soon as you've got multiple
people in a in a room the storytelling
of making sure that you're not jumping
camera shots too often because it
becomes quite confusing keeping a firm
idea of where people are and then sort
of finding the best way to keep it
visually interesting as well as not
confusing keeping everybody in the right
place and in the right order along the
length of the panel that in itself came
from blocking theatres doing doing
theater blocking and when I'm drawing
costumes I used to make costumes because
I can so I used to make a lot of custard
so I know how clothes are constructed
and whenever I'm sort of going through a
script I've read it a couple of times
before I sit down to thumbnail and even
then I will act out all the parts oh oh
oh that's my actor so yeah I will play
the part of you know Wonder Woman and
then I'll play the part of Steve and
I'll try to find the nuance in in asain
because sometimes there there's power
and subtlety that I find can be really
effecting there was a thing I use it as
an example quite a bit there was a scene
in the first issue of Teen Titans that I
drew when I was working with JT crawl on
Teen Titans um where Cassie and Connor
who had been boyfriend and girlfriend
for a while she was breaking out with
him and Cassie had kind of gone through
a period of time of fence getting
frustrated with her and I loved the
character and I wanted people to love
her again and I felt my god the first
thing she's doing is breaking out with
her boyfriend and everybody loves Connor
and this is gonna really break some
hearts
and it was kind of an argument that they
were having and it would have been very
easy for an artist to just sort of think
that they were shouting and just throw a
lot of shoddy faces and Cassie just
would not have come out of that
sympathetically and so I sort of floated
the idea or having acted it out a couple
of times I floated the idea to JT and to
our editor what if I made it like a
really quiet subtle scene with this
sitting in the room and they're sitting
on the edge of the bed and they're
holding hands and it's an emotional
conversation where we can feel sympathy
for both of the characters because that
would be better for me as a female
creator looking after my female
characters I know we're both like that's
a great idea do that so that's where
sort of the the the acting V scenes out
gives me sort of the different ways that
you can play a thing especially
emotionally-charged one you only have
about five minutes left and I noticed
that done it again notice that you left
the hair to the end and I've been told
that you sometimes spend a lot of time
on this particular aspect of a dry if I
am not under a time constraint and
sometimes even when I am I can get
really lost in the hair because it's it
becomes quite sort of like a meditation
you can just sort of keep going there's
been times I think that the most full-on
was when I was doing a blackest night
tying it was the first time I worked on
Wonder Woman with Greg Rucka it was the
blackest night Wonder Woman three-issue
arc and at the time my family was going
through a big thing my mom was really
sick and so I I didn't have a lot of
time but I really wanted to make this
series as good as it could be because it
was me finally getting to draw or Wonder
Woman us getting to work with Greg on
Wonder Woman and so it was a really big
deal to me and I find that when I'm
super stressed and super
busy you get into like a slipstream of
creativity and cunning in the zone yeah
it's you're like you you I find I
produce my best stuff when I have no
time to think about anything but I would
fall into spaces where I would just
start drawing curls and curls and
clothes of waving in the wind hair that
I would snap out of it and go oh my god
she's Rapunzel all of a sudden they'd be
like here for all the fall date and then
have to kind of rub it out and sort of
try and contain her crazy Medusa hair
but yes I find I find here is one of
those things that I can get very very
carried away with but when I'm doing
quick sketches it's usually the first
thing that goes out the window it
becomes real messy really quickly so you
imagine you work with Greg Rucka yeah
but you're not just working with just
Greg when you work on this do you have a
whole team of editorial staff and people
like that do you work with on these
projects what's it like to work with
those people it's like the work as that
sort of cohesive unit
we were fit for Wonder Woman rebirth we
were so so lucky that we just from the
get-go felt like a really cohesive team
um Liam's shop who was doing the
alternate issues he was doing the
present-day Wonder Woman's story he'd
been attached to the book for months and
was kind of waiting to for us to get
started and Greg and I came on a kind of
the 11th hour and it was only because
Greg and I have known each other for
such a long time and Diana is kind of
our favorite character when we've talked
about her a lot for about a decade so
that even though we just suddenly got
the book we already knew that we were
gonna be on the same page even though
you know there are a couple of things
that he put in for me like I'm a fan of
the invisible jet even though I know
it's a bit ridiculous and you know when
he said to me what do you you know what
do you want in the store
I was like I know you gonna kill me but
I really want the invisible dead he was
like Nicola explain it to me explain how
that is not going to be ridiculous and I
explained to him exactly what it is
where it came from how it is to be and
what its use is because we need it in
the story and he was like yeah alright
you got me
alright I'll write that in yeah and uh
and so you know we had a lot of fun but
the editorial group as well it was one
of those experiences where we were all
just wanting we were all we were all on
the same page in terms of totally what
we wanted to hear what marks we wanted
to it what story beats we wanted to hear
um and you know we we had quite the the
team at the time I think most of my most
of my sort of contact was with tey with
Rebecca Taylor and it was it was just it
was a joy it was one of the most
collaborative experiences because to
start off with Liam and Greg and I got
on skype a number of times and we just
blocked out the idea of both stories and
a lot of sort of design concept stuff
because we were all working from the
same pool and we all got to sort of
contribute interesting ideas it was just
one of the most collaborative
experiences I've ever had in sort of
mainstream comics and again we didn't
have a lot of time to prep because we
were announcing I think about seven days
after Greg and I were attached to the
books and just that sort of time
pressures just made us concentrate and
get right in there and have a lot of fun
so my last question to you sure it'd be
one woman eighty-four coming out next
year so excited so I've heard what is
the one thing that you would love to see
that you'd be so excited was in there I
have full faith in patty Jenkins because
every decision that she's made and every
creative idea that's made its way into
the film I felt incredibly in line with
you know Liam and I met her and go a
couple years ago at San Diego when we
did the Wonder Woman 75th anniversary
panel and it was the first time that we
were getting insight into what she was
doing with the movie and we were already
working on the series and what amazed me
was how much sort of we were on the same
page and it was like even though we're
dealing with the same character the
character hasn't been the version that
she's doing in the version that we're
doing for a while but there we were both
doing the same version we both source
Steve's the same way so that that is was
incredibly reassuring and I feel very
reassured from what I've seen so far of
the new one
I loved it she's kind of got rid of the
strap and that the lesser was attached
to the belt I love that she's got a
little more 80s height in her hair I
love it I love it I love it um you know
she's got a touch of glamour which you
know to me Wonder Woman has always had
but I think as a fan what I would have
to say I really want to see gal gadot
spin into that outfit I really want to
see a modern version of the spin because
it's so iconic yeah everybody knows that
and I felt like it could have even
existed at the very end of the first
movie when she's back in the Louvre and
she hears the sirens I feel like she
could have gone out and that rooftop and
spun and then jumped into the air and
the whole audience would have exploded
in their tea
you know so I'm getting the the cut
signal over there but base okay we're
going through is Nicolas gonna fish up
this drawing but we're gonna give it
away to someone sent the blonde sorry so
I have a trivia question if you've been
attention can you please tell me who was
her the other artist on her run with
Greg Rucka on the one who loan Liam sure
thank you so much
she needs some ladies and gentlemen we
give it up for Nicholas Scott please
thank you everyone who's this for